Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We recently talked about an amazing paper
that uses mixture theory to simulate the interaction
of liquids and fabrics.
And this new work is about simulating fluid
flows where we have some debris or other foreign
particles in our liquids.
This is really challenging.
For example, one of the key challenges is
incorporating two-way coupling into this process.
This means that the sand is allowed to have
an effect on the fluid, but at the same time,
as the fluid sloshes around, it also moves
the sand particles within.
Now, before you start wondering whether this
is real footage or not, the fact that this
is a simulation should become clear now, because
what you see here in the background is where
the movement of the two domains are shown
in isolation.
Just look at how much interaction there is
between the two.
Unbelievable.
Beautiful simulation, ice cream for your eyes.
This new method also contains a novel density
correction step, and if you watch closely
here, you’ll notice why.
Got it?
Let’s watch it again.
If we try to run this elastoplastic simulation
for these two previous methods, they introduce
here a gain in density, or in other words,
we end up with more stuff than we started
with.
These two rows show the number of particles
in the simulation in the worst case scenario,
and as you see, some of these incorporate
millions of particles for the fluid and many
hundreds of thousands for the sediment.
Since this work uses the material point method,
which is a hybrid simulation technique that
uses both particles and grids, the delta x
row denotes the resolution of the simulation
grid.
Now since these grids are often used for 3D
simulations, we need to raise the 256 and
the 512 to the third power, and with that,
we get a simulation grid with up to hundreds
of millions of points, and we haven’t even
talked about the particle representation yet!
In the face of all of these challenges, the
simulator is able to compute one frame in
a matter of minutes, and not hours or days,
which is an incredible feat.
With this, I think it is easy to see that
the computer graphics research is improving
at a staggering pace.
What a time to be alive!
If you enjoyed this episode, please make consider
supporting us through Patreon, our address
is Patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers, or just click
the link in the video description.
With this, we can make better videos for you.
You can also get your name immortalized in
the video description as a key supporter or
watch these videos earlier than others.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!